vendredi parce que c'était ce que je
suis auto chez moi j'ai la tarte flambée
qu il dit
[Musique]
vous n en avez la tarte flambée on peut
se du pain n'est ce pas et là ça plombe
et venait avant les princes des comptes
et ses débuts c'était notre dîner et je
pense que l'origine du flan ce jeu c'est
vraiment le repas du vendredi midi
il faut un bon four à pain chauffer au
feu de bois pendant deux heures environ
vous avez tout le temps de rap et les
oignons de couper les lardons
oh
et de mélanger le fromage blanc avec la
crème les eu un peu de sel et de pétré
en votre pâte à la main ou à la machine
[Musique]
afin de préparer la farine de l'eau ap
st et je la pratique pastorale et noir
sur une passe juste et à la party girl
n'a plus grands mm cela ressort cela
travail en grimpeur parce que dans la
bad il faut pas qu'il soit beaucoup
d'air
vous essayez d'avoir une patte de quelle
est l'épaisseur aussi mauvaise que
possible
vous la laissez reposer deux heures à
peu près et vous mettez la levure que
ces pactes monte
oui je prends du fromage plein j'achète
des aisselles les mélanges sage ajoute
la crème pour que l'eau n'était ce pas
trop coulant il faut acheter un peu de
farine
[Musique]
on met des signes au dessus tonio cru il
faut laisser les avances parfait
s'introduire contre les manches
[Musique]
ils sont venus en revenus comme la wii
il ya tant d'enfants ne mettez pas de la
jeunesse jamais mangé avec l'art
et avant de l'enfourner il faut mettre
un peu d'huile dessus pour que la baisse
pas trop sèche mais dans le temps un
homme blanc boy huile de colza
c'était meilleur parce qu'il qui
n'empêche pas
[Musique]
au milieu du four dégager des braises et
nettoyer à détendre les limites
la tarte flambée est léchée par les
flammes
m
on peut la manger chez soi en famille
comme ici chez angèle
de toute façon on partage la tarte
flambée
on la mange toujours un plusieurs ainsi
elle n'a pas le temps de refroidir
m
à sept mois maintenant c'est quand même
les dix meilleurs
la tarte flambée est sorti du cadre
familial
il ya une quinzaine d'années environ
lorsque certains patrons de bure
wirtschaft de ces bistrots de campagne
ont décidé de dépoussiérer leurs fours
et de servir la tarte flambée aux
villageois les samedis et dimanches
soirs comme ici à willgottheim quand
j'ai débuté j'ai vraiment pris le
système de ma grand mère parce que je me
rappelle que les vendredis c'était
c'était vraiment le retrait du ventre
vide
après après le potache être simple
otages comme s occupait à cuire le pain
dans la crise une enfant y avait une
vingtaine en tout comme ici j'aime j'ai
un peu pris cette image
et alors là elle nous servait le potager
dans la cuisine on mangeait de flandre
finalement j'ai vu les plans d'une
affaire à moi
je ne suis pas assis c'est bien ils
resserrent et
gène je me souvenais comme on le faisait
ma grand mère n'a pas de la page
il ajouté
la crème
et avec ma mère
cette affaire vraiment à l'ancienne je
pense continuer sur cette lancée et
toujours le faire
avec
employés qui sont effectivement des
paysannes
un peu à la retraite maintenant je crois
qu'on a gardé longtemps très longtemps
les traditions en a dans cette région du
kochersberg entre autres qui sont en
train de tourner un peu ce qui restait
absolument une recette comme on
c'est déjà là
sentant mais derrière caen caen
pare-feux c'est de cette manière
et je pense que vous fassiez de la même
manière
oui c'est le frère
et avant on fait celle
dior l'inter milan
lee parce que les femmes vous savez
beaucoup de travail et il se mettait à
hurler
et il connaît
m
a pris tout le soin à même je me
souviens que ma grand mère mais ma mère
vous passez d'abord une ficelle en
dessous la partie des années que conte
en forme mieux et on est très déçu c'est
est-ce que plus parce qu'on a moi même
je la préfère nature juste avec de
l'huile de colza mais alors sans l'art
sans oignons
juste le fromage c'est la crème et
l'huile de forme ça je pense que chez
vous comme
vous cessiez de la même manière
enlever les blessés
whissell
ainsi dans l'islam
à ce qui paraît la tradition voudrait
que le vent comme c'était le repas du
vendredi
pour les villages platonique ne mettait
pas de l'art et dans les villages
protestants il y mettait du large
mais je me rappelle effectivement que ma
grand mère ne manquait juste avec des
oignons
et souvent ils faisaient revenir les
autres
elle n'était pas tellement les oignons
crus avec l'aps
[Musique]